voile alors j'ai beaucoup réfléchi et
j'ai décidé d'arrêter de faire des
vidéos sur youtube jury goal évidemment
je continue les vidéos toute ma vie vers
l'infini pour la première fois je vous
fais une vidéo là c'est parce qu'elle
joue quoi c'est une vidéos informatives
je veux simplement vous donner quelques
informations
[Musique]
mes chansons ça fait très longtemps que
beaucoup d'entre vous me demander quand
est-ce qu'on pourra écouter mes chansons
sur des plates formes des coûts tels que
deezer spotify est tout et moi je vous
répondais pas parce que je suis un gros
bâtard finalement j'ai pris tout ça en
main et désormais vous écouter librement
toutes mes chansons sur deezer spotify
apple musique et itunes
à vous de choisir j'ai regroupé tous ces
morceaux se forme une playlist mais j'ai
pas trop comment l'appeler parce que
c'est vrai que c'est ni un album ni un
ep et le terme compilation ça faisait un
peu années 90 il norman compilation qui
demeure 2017 avec ton booty tout l'été
sur des rythmes chaudement haute avec
chérie fm et produit par michel blanc
salut c'est michel blanc sur chérie fm
j'ai produit cet album et c'est de la
bande de balle fils de [ __ ] du coup j'ai
appelé ça mais gros son même s'ils sont
pas spécialement gros bref culture dans
le bus dans la cour de récré dans ton
[ __ ] taf peut écouter zelda luigi
clash mario franson internet de l'époque
assassins des templiers et assassins des
templiers version acoustique
soyez pas étonné s'il ya un ou deux
morceaux manquants c'est en cours donc à
les écouter ça sur vos plateformes
préférées mauvais votre nas chaîne
secondaire autre grande nouvelle que
j'ai désormais une chaîne youtube
secondaire c'est-à-dire une deuxième
chaîne youtube
j'ai tout simplement appelée norman le
chêne secondaire bon arrêtez les vrais
savent que c'est une vieille chaîne
secondaire que je ressors des abysses
dessus je mets plein de vidéos je me
prends un peu moins la tête des vidéos
un peu improvisé freestyle l'occurrence
en ce moment beaucoup de vidéos de
gaming notamment avec hugo à mais pas
que s'appelle gaming entre potes
qu'éminent entrepôts et ça va être
qu'avant clair
et on dit des conneries un peu plus cru
que d'habitude vu que c'est une chaîne
secondaire on s'en fout no limit no
filter et puis des fois il y aura des
poteaux en invité pour jouer avec nous
par exemple les prochains c'est les
frérots de la vega non non frérot ses
berlines
je suis déçu il ya un bus le 8 mars pour
l'instant j'ai pas appeler ça norman
gaming parce que déjà ses prix en a déjà
fait son sprint sur toi en tout le monde
et en plus de sueur a pas que du gaming
et peut-être que sur cette chaîne
bientôt il y aura aussi des petits
débats entre potes des ambiances radios
libres avec les abonnés bref cette
chaîne c'est un peu un labo quoi ouais
j'ai une chaîne labo si vous aimez
l'idée abonnez vous les abonnés dans ma
vidéo vous le savez peut-être mais
bientôt grâce à vous on va passer la
barre des 10 millions d'abonnés youtube
pour fêter ça je vais me bourrer la
gueule mais aussi je prépare une grosse
vidéo youtube
enfin une vidéo assez grosse enfin plus
grosse que les autres et vu que mine de
rien cette aventure youtube passé grâce
à vous j'ai envie que vous fassiez
partie de cette vidéo
j'ai besoin de vous avez dû je vais rien
vous spoiler mais en gros c'est une
petite histoire que j'ai inventé et à un
moment donné dans cette histoire je vois
mes abonnés en train de regarder mes
vidéos pour participer envoyez moi une
vidéo devenue en train de norman non ça
c'est le casting de morandini ça ah
merde ok mais plus sérieusement pour
participer envoyez moi une vidéo de vous
d'environ une minute vous faites style
de regarder des vidéos tu vois en
rigolant ou en souriant donc si mes
vidéos font pas rire du tout bas fait
semblant 1 s'il vous plaît il faut que
ce soit filmé avec la caméra intérieure
de votre téléphone tablette ou
ordinateur eux sans regarder l'objectif
en regardant l'écran ça doit être bien
cadré bien éclairé c'est important en
souriant ou en rigolant légèrement sans
en faire des caisses vous pouvez aussi
le faire sur un ordi ça doit durer une
minute comme ça un os un peu flou mais
je vous
ça rendra bien inutile de faire des
trucs exubérant ou de parler hein et
norman le sort que tu peux passer un big
up au lycée jean moulin
merci mon frère tout tout seul parce que
sera pas cohérent avec le reste
alors je pourrai pas le mettre dans le
montage et envoyez votre vidéo à go to
10 millions @ gmail point com par mail
par ouï transfert comme vous voulez
attention évidemment tout le monde ne
pourra pas être dans le montage final
même si j'en ai très envie je peux pas
mettre 10 millions de vidéos dans
montage final ça ferait une vidéo de
huit heures donc je vais devoir un
moment sélectionner un petit peu au
hasard en tirant au sort évidemment en
présence d'huissiers
donc je suis ici avec m blanchard et m
maître gims voilà avant de donner les
résultats je tiens à dire que les votes
ont été très serrés non mais je ne sens
n'a pas commencé le concours a pas
commencé ta t'as pas compris cette vidéo
d'information est désormais terminé tout
de suite la météo présentée par bonsoir
alors il fera 18 degrés à lille 14
degrés à toulouse
bref j'espère que vous avez qui fait ses
petites infos plutôt positive n'oubliez
pas de vous abonner à ma chaîne youtube
secondaire que vous connaissez
maintenant et aussi à ma chaîne youtube
principal pour atteindre les 10 millions
d'abonnés c'est maintenant ou jamais et
dès qu'on passe la barre des 10 millions
je sors une vidéo exceptionnelle avec
vous de danger juste hyper hate you tube
10 millions ciao